Speaker 1: So this is very interesting.
We have resolution in some sense to one of
the many election lie related lawsuits that
are taking place.
It's important to follow these stories to
their conclusions.
Newsmax is one of the right wing media networks
that was spreading known, demonstrable, debunked
lies about the twenty twenty election in the
months after the November election.
One of the targets of these lies was Dominion
Voting Systems, which attracted the ire of
Fox News, Newsmax, Rudy Giuliani, Sydney Powell,
the My Pillow guy.
Many people going bonkers about Dominion voting
system supposed role in helping to steal the
election for Donald Trump, from Donald Trump.
For Joe Biden.
Newsmax specifically made such claims as Eric
Coomber, an executive at Dominion, was supposedly
part of an Antifa conference call to rig the
election.
There were also other claims about exactly
how Dominion voting systems stole votes from
Trump and gave them to Biden.
There's no evidence for any of this stuff.
There never was.
So Dominion voting systems decided to sort
of try to throw the book at.
These people sued Newsmax.
Among others, and the Newsmax lawsuit has
now been settled, this is the first such settlement.
We don't know the financial terms of the settlement,
but presumably there is a financial payoff
here by Newsmax.
And of course, we are led to believe that
this is only the first of many, but this is
just the best tail between the legs outcome.
Newsmax has published an apology.
Now, the apology is sort of B.S., but it's
still interesting to look at.
First of all, they published it with the completely
anodyne title statement about Dr. Eric Coomer,
director of product strategy and security
at Dominion Voting Systems.
OK, so let's look at this.
This is the retraction and apology.
Newsmax says since Election Day, various guests,
attorneys and hosts on Newsmax have offered
opinions and claims about Dr. Eric Kumah Newsmax.
We'd like to clarify its coverage of Dr. Coomber
and note that while Newsmax initially covered
claims by President Trump's lawyers, supporters
and others that Dr. Coomber played a role
in manipulating, manipulating Dominion voting
machines, Dominion voting software and the
final vote counts in the twenty election,
Newsmax subsequently found no evidence that
such allegations were true.
So already they're framing it.
As we were bystanders here, we did nothing.
There were people who came on and made claims.
When we looked into the truth of the claims,
we found no evidence for them.
Now, this is a very sort of cynical view on
the role of Newsmax.
They knew from day one that there was no evidence,
but they continue to allow the claims to be
made.
So even the framing of the apologies is pretty
much B.S. Newsmax going on to say many of
the states whose results were contested by
the Trump campaign have conducted recounts
and audits and each state certified the results
is legal and final.
There are several facts our viewers should
be aware of.
This is great news.
Max has found no evidence that Dr. Coomber
interfered with Dominion voting machines or
voting software in any way, nor that Dr. Coomber
ever claimed to have done so.
Nor has Newsmax found any evidence that Dr.
Coomber ever participated in any conversation
with members of Antifa, nor that he was directly
involved with any partizan political organization
on behalf of Newsmax.
We would like to apologize for any harm our
reporting of the allegations against Coomber
may have caused to Dr. Coomber and his family.
For more, go to our website and read facts
about Dominion now.
I love that they did this, but this is one
of the most B.S. apologies and retractions
I've seen.
Because, I mean, listen, first of all, in
general, with these apologies and retractions,
they did months of the coverage and now almost
no one is going to hear or value this apology,
which is so narrow in scope.
Understand that they're not even retracting
general claims made about dominion.
All they are saying is the specific claims
guests made about Dr. Koumas role are without
evidence.
A lot of the claims were more broad about
Dominion voting systems as an as an entity,
as an organization.
They're not even retracting or apologizing
about that.
Nevermind all of this other stuff.
Claims from Sydney Powell and Mike Pelo about
Venezuela, Hugo Chavez, whatever.
OK, so listen up.
Presumably Newsmax decided to settle to avoid
going forward because it would cost them a
lot more money.
There's a risk for Dominion.
Also, if the lawsuit were to move forward
and go to court, maybe Dominion doesn't win
the defamation suit.
Who knows?
Both parties decided it was in their interest
to settle.
But I received some emails from people saying,
you know, the apology is so narrow and such
B.S. that no one will see.
It might be more impactful if one of these
lawsuits really lead to the complete and total
demise of an organization like Newsmax.
I can see both sides because there are risks
to going to trial.
I'm sure both sides accounted for those risks
in making their decision to settle.
Now, in terms of what Newsmax really believes
as an entity, it is obvious Newsmax never
believe this stuff.
Ever, ever, ever.
They are the there are people taking the position
that Newsmax is saying this now only because
they have to, but they still believe the election
was stolen.
No, no, no, no, no.
Maybe there are some hosts individually that
believe the election was stolen.
I think the reality is Newsmax as an entity
never believed this.
They were going with it and allowing guests
to push it for clicks.
That's all it was.
I don't think there was any point at which
Newsmax had an editorial position that this
election was stolen by Joe Biden.
This is now one settlement.
We will see what more comes of it.
There are many more of these in play